Why?
Why do we have nuclear files attacking things with leaving groups on them?
What's the orbital that makes those things reactive?
The substrate reactive,
not the nucleophile,
the duplicate files a high home,
right?
It's a low Lumo.
So
what do you read?
The attack Al Kill highlights.
It's because of the low Lumo when you attack alkenes the characteristic
functionality,
the double bond is mostly remarkable because it's a high homo,
right?
So we talk about electrophilic addition to double bonds.
So it's low lumos that are attacking double bonds like age plus.
But many of the reagents that do this that are classed as nuclear,
as electrophilic addition reagents also have,
uh,
have high homos.
So they also functioned as a files.
So the subject of the lecture today is electrophilic conditioned to double
bonds,
but stressing that there's also a nucleophile and that may be participating at
the same time,
that can react with the Lumo of the,
uh,
alkene that is the Pi Star.
Okay.
First,
uh,
I wanted to suggest a problem for you to work on.
Uh,
the pinnacle rearrangement is a neat,
uh,
rearrangement.
Notice that the way the carbons are connected together and the product Bunac
alone is different from the way they're connected in the starting material
called pinnacle,
that the origin of that name is interesting.
It's comes from a Greek word,
ancient Greek word for tablet.
It was coined in 1859 is a name for this compound because of the it's crystals
where we're plates.
So,
so it was called,
uh,
pinnacle because of the pretty plates of the hydrate crystal.
But anyhow,
see if you,
this'll be good exercise for you to draw a nice curved arrows that start where
they should start and end where they should add,
uh,
to show how you do this.
It requires several steps,
so that'll be fun for you.
Okay.
Now,
last time we talked about rearrangement in particular that when you had,
uh,
acid reacting with the alkene,
you got rearrangement of the product.
So for example,
you add the Proton to get the more stable cad ion the secondary instead of the
primary,
but there's a more stable when still,
which is the tertiary.
So it involves a meth.
I'd shift that we talked about last time and the product then when you add water
and then lose a proton from that group is this rearranged alcohol.
So this could be a problem if you wanted to get the unreached arranged alcohol,
you couldn't do it by acid catalyzed hydration.
Okay.
All right.
But there's an alternative called oxy mercury [inaudible] reduction,
right?
So the oxy mercury station ads,
mercury and uh,
Ooh to the double bond,
but the electro file or probably the,
you know,
the electro file is the mercury plus two cad.
I am.
So one of the acetates comes off and you add the mercury and then there's a
second reaction in this,
in this sequence.
First,
the oxy mercury nation,
then a reduction which avoids rearrangement.
So it gives the alcohol that you would have expected if you hadn't been a
sophisticated enough to suspect rearrangement of the secondary to the tertiary
cad.
I am now let's think how this works and why it works.
We're here.
What it,
when you get a rearrangement,
when you have a proton,
the Proton is small and isn't able to overlap well with both carbons at the same
time.
We talked about the fact that it gives a double minimum,
right?
It can rearrange hydrogen with its electrons.
Hydride can shift the same way method shifted in the rearrangement we just
talked about on the previous slide,
right?
But it goes over a barrier,
Whereas mercury is a much larger ion and is big enough to overlap with both
carbons at the same time.
So it's a single minimum instead of rearranging over a bump from one to the
other side,
it lives near the middle.
Okay?
So as shown there,
now it's a why bond,
right?
The electrons that were in the Pi bond to the carbon carbon double bond are now
shared with the vacant orbital on the mercury cad I.
And so it's one of those,
uh,
three center to electron bonds that we talked about before.
Okay?
So now since the mercury is bonded to both carbons,
you can't get the rearrangement right
now.
Uh,
here we draw a resonance structures to,
uh,
to denote the bonding that we also can denote by that why upside down wide in
this case.
Uh,
but notice that I haven't drawn it symmetrical,
right?
The Mercury Adam is not in the middle,
halfway between the two carbons.
We can have the three resonance structures on the right with mercury plus on the
left with a primary carbon plus and on the far left with a secondary carbon
plus,
but that's secondary cad ion would be thought to be more stable than the primary
one.
So I won't surprise you that the best position for the mercury is not halfway
between the carbons,
but nearer the one on the left.
So that,
that it's the most important presidents structure.
Right.
And what that means is that the cat ion that is mostly on the,
the uh,
the,
uh,
secondary carbon and that bond is a weaker,
the bond on the left,
the red bond shown here is stronger.
So when,
when the nucleophile comes in,
in the second stage and the reaction when the water comes in,
it attacks that cat eye and not the other one.
If it were symmetrically bridged,
you would think that it could attack both of them,
right?
Maybe 50,
50,
but in fact that attacks that one.
So it gives this product that's the,
that's the,
uh,
hydroxy mercury ration product,
right?
The hydroxy mercury [inaudible] product addition to the double bond,
That then nobody wants that.
But you can remove the mercury by treating with the reducing agent sodium
borohydride and it's replaced then by hydrogen.
So this subsequent reduction step,
uh,
by the Bh four and ion completes Markov knockoff hydration.
Notice that it's the same orientation of alcohol that you would have gotten with
h plus.
It's the more stable of the two cad ions that you could get as a primary account
ion or a secondary cad.
I am the,
the nucleophile Ooh,
went to the more substituted carbon.
Right?
So it's more common to call for,
it's the same product you'd get,
but you suppress the rearrangement by the fact that the mercury was bonded to
both carbons at once and didn't allow the,
the,
uh,
method to shift.
Okay.
Uh,
now,
uh,
this,
this idea of bridging and unsymmetrical bridging occurs also in the addition of
Halogens to the double bonds,
chlorine and bromine.
These are,
uh,
examples from the lecture that Professor Siegel gave last year.
So they show you the way you would write this,
uh,
quickly.
And notice that the addition of Calori add cl and o h cl goes in this case to
the primary carbon and Ooh,
to the,
uh,
to the more substituted carbon analogous to the way in the previous slide,
mercury went to the,
to the,
uh,
less substituted carbon and Ooh,
to the,
ultimately to the more substituted carbon.
So it's Markovnikov addition.
Now,
what was the,
uh,
electro file?
What was it?
The thing that added to give a carbon cat I,
and intermediate in this case here,
Ooh,
came in as a nucleophile in the second step,
right?
And then lost the Proton to it.
Water came in last,
a proton to give ohs,
but chlorine must've been the electro file.
That meant it was something like cl plus,
not cl minus,
which are usually think about.
So let's,
uh,
contemplate this reaction and a little more detail.
So here's ethylene viewed edge on and we can,
uh,
the electrified will attack it's homo,
which looks like that.
Now the electro file is going to be chlorine.
Now what orbital is the Lumo of chlorine
cl two
carbon.
You got an idea,
right?
Sigma Stars.
That is it.
So let's draw the sigma star orbital.
The Lumo is sigma star.
So it looks like that.
Does that look good to you Arvind?
At first,
is it,
is,
is the energy match good?
Is it unusually low?
Lumo Sigma Star of cl two.
Ah,
it is unusually low because it's,
it's chlorine.
Big nuclear charge.
So low energy.
But as you say,
the overlap is bad,
right?
It looks almost orthogonal.
Right?
So what could you do about that?
How could you increase the overlap?
Do you have any idea?
If you were in,
if you were in nuclear file,
a high homo and wanted to attack that Lumo,
the sigma star of Clc l,
where would you approach from?
Would you approach the way the ethylene is doing here?
Where would you come from?
You'd approached from one of the ends,
right,
where you get overlap without hitting the wrong orbital.
So what,
what do you need to do to the picture?
Right?
You need to rotate the chlorine because you have poor overlap here.
But if you rotate the chlorine and it looks just fine,
so now you can take the electrons in the homo and mix them with this Pi star or
but all,
which means,
remember there's anti-bonding,
it's an antibiotic orbital of cl two.
So we can draw arrows like this,
break the CLC and Oban.
So it looks like the nuclear filex substitution reaction at what Adam,
what Adam's being attacked.
If this is a nuclear filling substitution,
the chlorine,
it's a nuclear affiliate substitution of chlorine.
Okay?
So that's what we would get,
uh,
where,
where the,
the one,
the chlorine plus has attacked the,
uh,
the CC double bond and formed this three membered ring,
still a cat ion and chlorine minus has gone away.
It took the electrons that were in the sigma,
uh,
in the sigma orbital.
Okay?
So there's a,
what's going on?
So there's,
if you consider this product,
the two different species in the product as one,
that's the homo,
it's where the electrons have this chlorine chlorine bond went right that the
top Arrow,
curved Arrow,
right?
And this is the Hobo minus two and that you can see is distorted,
but it's the Pi orbital of um,
of the,
uh,
c c double bond mixed with the p orbital on the chlorine or some hybrid orbital
of the chloride to form the bond in the blue region there.
That's where the Pi electrons went.
Okay,
but notice this is homo minus two.
Where is the homo and where is homo minus one of this product pair of things.
Okay,
so let's look at it again.
Notice that there are two chlorine chlorine bonds drawn in this three membered
ring.
So there must be some other pair of electrons.
It's involved if we can draw two bonds.
Okay,
where did those other two electrons come from?
That other pair.
Okay,
well we had the Lumo on ethylene Pi Star and the homo on chlorine.
Now what do you think the Hobo on cl two would be
Roy?
So it's a p orbital on one of the chlorine's and unshared pair.
In fact,
in the,
so we now want to chlorine nucleophile so it's that unshared pair.
In fact,
if we want to draw the molecular orbital that has it,
uh,
the,
the high homo,
it turns out to be the analog of Pi Star.
It's not only the,
the p orbital on the bottom,
uh,
chlorine,
which would be a relatively high in energy,
but it's a mixture with the p orbital of the other chlorine overlapping with it
anti-bonding to raise the energy.
So it's still higher in energy than it would be if it were just a single p
orbital.
So it's this orbital here and you see it's precisely set up to form good
overlap.
So it's elect those electrons on the chlorine will be stabilized by the Lumo of
the ethylene at the same time that the sigma star or a bottle of the chlorine is
stabilizing the Pi electrons.
So it mixes both ways.
The chlorine is both an electrified and a nucleophile.
Two different pairs of electrons are involved and that gives the homeowner minus
one.
Right,
which you see,
so now we have two pairs of electrons that are,
that are,
uh,
forming those bonds and the three,
this new bonds in the three membered ring.
Right?
So we can denote that this way.
Now,
where is the homo?
That's just an unshared pair on the oxygen that wasn't involved in this because
it's orthogonal to the other bonds.
It's in and out of the plane of the,
uh,
so that's,
that's the homeless.
We've seen the,
the,
uh,
homo,
the homo minus one in the home or minus to that thing.
And there's the,
there's the Lumo,
which is the,
uh,
anti-bonding combination of the chlorine and the,
and the Pi.
Okay.
So we've traced this through,
but the crucial lesson is that there were two reactions going on that chlorine
acting as a nucleophile as well as,
as an electrified.
So all the,
you call it electrophilic addition and sort of imagine that it's cl plus
attacking,
right?
In fact,
both things are happening at the same time and two bonds are being formed.
Now.
What would happen next?
There's the Lumo and we have the home of the cl minus I,
and that was formed at the same time.
So if those two reacted in the way shown here,
it would be the exact reverse of what that you'd form a new bond between
chlorine and chlorine.
You'd put electrons into this Lumo.
This bond would break and you'd go back to the starting material,
but there's a different arrangement that will allow you to go on from here
toward different products,
which is to move that chloride an independent eye.
And after all down to the bottom.
So now we have that chloride unshared,
pair homo,
and this Lumo and they can interact with one another like this.
Right.
What kind of reaction does that remind you of?
Did you ever see a reaction like that before?
It's like opening it up.
Oxide,
which is it an even more general sense?
An sn two reaction,
right?
A nucleophile attacking a Lumo,
Which is anti bonding.
And here the leaving group leaves,
it's an attack on carbon.
Okay.
So that then would open up the ring and give addition of two chlorines to the,
to the carbon carbon double bond.
So you can think of at first as addition of cl plus and then addition of cl
minus,
right?
It's a two step process.
But the interesting thing is that that first step involve both nucleophile and
an electro file,
uh,
activity of the chlorine.
So we could draw it again here.
That first step,
it makes two,
two bonds of the three membered ring wallet breaks the chlorine chlorine bond.
So the red is what you normally think of as an electrified,
all attacking the double bond,
but the blue is a nucleophile attacking.
So it's an electrophilic addition of cl two to an alkene.
That's both electrophilic and nuclear fillic simultaneously.
Okay.
Which generates this so-called chloro knee on them.
I am this three membered ring,
a intermediate,
which then undergoes an sn two reaction to open up and give the product.
Now,
uh,
I remember a,
since it's two steps,
the nucleophile in the second step doesn't have to be the chloride.
It could be some other nuclear file.
For example,
you could do this reaction,
generate that intermediate,
but then have water come in and be the nucleophile,
in which case the chloride would,
would go away and you'd lose the Proton.
So you,
the product is Hcl,
that product not shown as Hcl,
but you have the,
uh,
you have the,
compound that's called a hallow hydron.
Now let's look at the,
uh,
bro Ammonium ion that you get when you add br two and look at the regio
chemistry that's involved.
So the,
you have the,
there's three membered ring,
but it's not symmetrical.
The bromine,
I've drawn more on the right than on the left.
Why would I draw it that way?
Conor,
do you have any idea why not?
Put it in the middle,
right?
The more substituted carbon on the left is a better place to have a cat ion,
So you have a stronger bond on the right,
a longer weaker bond on the left.
So it's an unsymmetrical bridged bro Ammonium Ion,
right?
And then if the bromide comes in backside at the carbon to do,
it's sn two reaction,
right?
You get the,
the uh,
the product that's just like the one we showed before with chlorine.
It's a too bro means that have added in this case
and that's,
but that's only formed in 24% yield in this case.
What do you think the dominant product is?
Okay.
Antonio,
can you see any alternative?
Yeah.
Well you could add to the other side,
but we've just been talking about,
I mean on the right rather than on the left.
You could,
but that's,
that would be not preferred.
You might say maybe steric hindrance would help it attack from the right,
but in fact it doesn't attack from the right because of the unsymmetrical
nature.
The bond between bromine and carbon is stronger in the right,
the positive charge is bigger on the left.
So that's where the bromide attacks.
So it's not that it attacks on the right,
but there's another possibility.
Anybody got an idea?
Pardon me?
Aha.
The water can attack.
So in case instead of the bromide,
the water could come back backside the carbon and do it's trick.
Right?
And 60% of the PR,
the 60% yield.
In this case he does the Bromo hydrant.
So this is a competition between forming the,
the hallow hydrogen and forming the Dye haylight
and notice that it shows Markovnikov Riggio chemistry for the reasons we've just
been,
uh,
just been,
detailing that the,
that the electro file that added first was borough mean gave the more stable cad
ion.
Right?
Or unsymmetrical the thing that had more positive charge here and that's where
the water,
the nucleophile ends up on the more substituted carbon.
Right.
Okay.
But how do we know the eye and is bridged?
The same thing would happen if we hadn't formed that second bond,
right?
If it had just been like h plus,
if the bromine had just attacked to give the more stable cad I rather than a
bridged one,
how could you know that it's bridged?
What,
what effect was there from bridging in the case of Mercury?
Yeah,
Arvin,
there'd be no rearrangement.
That's one possible.
That's one thing you can do,
but there's another as well.
Another way of showing that.
And this,
uh,
is the key to it here,
that it's stereo specific.
If you start with the Trans or the sis to beauty,
you get different stereo chemical dye,
bromides stereo,
chemically different dye bromides.
But we'll look at it in another case here.
Suppose you have a ring compound like cyclohexene and you had bromine,
you get the borough ammonium ion,
obviously,
uh,
both bonds and the three membered ring have to be on the same face of the six
membered ring.
Okay.
And then when you have backside attack by the water,
uh,
it must form that compound.
It can't form the Oah on the same phase as the Broccoli,
right?
Dsn to process,
it has to be a backside,
not a front side of the TAC.
So whether it's the,
a Oah and you're forming the hallow hydrant,
or whether it's br minus and you attack the form of the dye bromide,
in either case,
it has to be a trans product,
right?
They have the bromine and the other,
the nucleophile have to be on opposite sides of the ring.
So,
so an unbridgeable c plus the nucleophile could have attacked from the top or
the bottom if the bromine we're bridging.
So the,
the bridging is evidenced not only by a lack of rearrangement,
but also by the,
by the stereo chemistry of the product.
It's an anti edition.
The reverse you notice of anti elimination that we talked about.
Uh,
uh,
e two reactions.
Now,
how about other kinds of reagents that can be both an file and a nucleophile at
the same time due to things.
There are a lot of them.
There are things called carbines.
There's a,
the reagent involved in hydro more ration,
which are things that have a BH bond in them.
Uh,
there's a thing called a carbon oid,
which involves these reagents.
There's an oxidation which forms the three membered ring with oxygen by a per
Roxy acid.
There's Ozo analysis oh three to form a five membered ring initially.
And there's this thing we referred to last time where I remember h two doesn't
have the proper symmetry of its orbitals to add directly to a CC double bond.
But with the help of a metal that can,
and that's another case where you have simultaneous nucleophile and electro file
behavior.
So we're going to go through these.
We won't get through all of them today to see how these agents work.
And finally there's,
there's a polymerization,
which is another topic that we'll get to that.
Okay.
So first car beans.
Now there was a fellow named Jack Hein who got his phd in 1950 and went to be a
postdoctoral with Professor Bartlett,
your chemical grandfather.
Uh,
and when Bartlet spoke about this sometime,
he,
he mentioned that the project that hind decided to work on all,
on his own,
I believe without much guidance from,
from Bartlett as opposed to doctoral,
was the reaction of,
of uh,
chloro methane's with hydroxide.
Now by 1950,
this was pretty old hat,
right?
Because these,
in 19,
the reaction had been known right from the time of,
uh,
of,
Williamson ether synthesis a hundred years earlier and all this stuff about sn
one sn,
two e one e two at all been done in the 1920s,
thirties.
So this was pretty old Bartlett said,
described this.
He said it was about his earthy who research project.
It could be appropriate for a postdoctoral but high knew what he was doing.
He had an interesting idea.
He was talking,
he was following up on,
he found that the reaction with hydroxide with the,
with the chloroform is very fast.
Right?
With methylene chloride is a w wait a second,
I've got the first one is supposed to be ch three cl,
I'm sorry,
I put it in there wrong.
So with methyl chloride as fast with methylene chloride,
it slow with Carbon Tetra chloride,
it's very slow.
Now if you were thinking of the halogens as roughly like a methyl group,
right,
which of which there are about the same size,
then this looks like the same.
Stearic affect you.
That was well known already in the rates of sn.
Two reactions.
That methyl is faster than Ethel is faster than than uh,
than T.
Beautiful.
Okay.
So that that much is,
is sensible.
What was interesting was this,
that chloroform is fast.
What does that suggest to you?
We saw this before.
I just in general,
what do you want?
It saw it before that when we were doing sn two reactions,
right?
They had a methyl ethyl ISO propyl,
and suddenly t butyl was very fast.
What did that suggest?
It's suggested,
yeah,
that there's a chain,
there's a different mechanism being involved in that reaction somehow,
right?
Since it doesn't fall in line.
Now what's special about,
uh,
about that?
Well,
he also could study the reaction with,
with,
uh,
with this sulfur and iron,
right?
Which is a nucleophile,
Hydroxide smaller,
better overlapped with hydrogen is a good base,
right?
But fennel sulfide is a,
is a better,
better as a nucleophile veteran bonded to carbon.
So it's the thing that would be doing the sn two kind of reaction,
and that is fast,
slow,
and very slow,
which makes sense for chloroform.
So it's something about o h minus being a base,
right?
That makes chloroform on unusual hind discovered.
Okay.
So what it is,
is when you have a very strong base,
like the bass from t butyl alcohol,
TB top side,
it turns out that they can extract h plus,
right?
Because the electronegative three chlorine make the carbon anti and sufficiently
stable that it could lose h plus.
It's not as strong acid to lose age plus,
but it's much better than having just two or only one chlorine.
All right?
So you can do this sn two reaction that hydrogen and get the try chloro methyl
an ion,
but then it has a good leaving group on it chloride,
right?
So you get elimination of Hcl from a single carbon,
It's Alpha elimination.
We talked about Beta elimination before in the two.
He won reaction where you take hydrogen proton off from one chloride or
whatever,
leaving group off from the adjacent one.
But this is loosely them,
both from the same atom and it's,
uh,
and chloroform is uniquely set up to do that.
Obviously carbon tetrachloride can't do it because it doesn't have the proton to
be lost.
Okay?
So now we have this divalent carbon,
which is called the car bead,
and it can come together with the,
uh,
with the Obgyn to form a cycle of propane.
Uh,
no.
And so we're gonna try,
we're gonna analyze this in terms of the homos,
a little bows that are involved in mixing the orbitals of the,
of the,
uh,
the carby in the Dye chlorocarbon with ethylene.
Okay.
So here are the,
our reagents.
We know the orbitals of ethylene.
So here's the whole ball of Dye chlorocarbon,
which turns out to be a bent molecule.
Right?
And here's its Lumo,
the vacant p orbital.
Now does that look well set up to react with ethylene?
The Mix Hobo with lube oil and lube oil with Hobo?
Yeah.
Noel,
what's the shape of,
uh,
of the,
of the Hobo of ethylene?
That's the thing that I liked her files usually attack.
What is it?
It's the pie.
So it would be positive here and positive here.
Is that well set up to mix with this Lumo?
No,
cause the Lumos a p orbital,
a B plus on one side and minus on the other,
they'd be orthogonal.
And the same is true.
The Lumo of the ethylene is,
is,
would be plus here minus here.
And this one is symmetrically between,
they would both be orthogonal,
right?
So both the homeowner Lumo and the Lumo Homo pairs are orthogonal.
So it doesn't look like,
uh,
like die chloral carbon should be able to do this to form these two bonds at
once.
But there's a way to do it.
And the person who can tell us how to do it as Arvind,
Aha.
Well rotate it,
right?
So this is actually that the three frames through the transition state,
This is just before the transition state.
But notice the dye chloro carbon is coming in sideways rather than head on,
right?
So the,
that,
that bond is being formed,
the two bonds are being formed,
the pie are going here.
The,
the,
uh,
loads of that hybrid orbital here are going into this.
So,
so we'll watch the,
uh,
motion here,
back up,
come forward again.
So what happens actually as you go through the transition state is it's
rotating,
right?
Does it start?
It starts getting overlapped with the thing.
And then as the new bonds form,
it goes into the lower energy geometry of the,
of the three member during which of course has the chlorine is pointing up.
Okay.
So,
so then this is the Lumo of the,
I use dye fluorocarbon for to have fewer electrons in order to do the
calculation.
But then,
but you see that the Lubo is the p orbital on the,
on the,
uh,
die chlorocarbon as we suspected,
the homo is the Pi of the alkene and they overlap well and then the home,
Oh,
is that a sp hybrid on the carbon.
And that's well set up to overlap with the Lumo.
So again,
you can do both electrophilic and nuclear fillic attack at the same time,
but it requires coming inside ways and rotating.
Okay.
Now how would we know that both bonds form at once because an alternative,
yeah.
The mechanism would be for this thing to act as if it were a radical for one
electronic come in here,
one electron of the Pi bond to go here and the other to go on here to give this
dye radical intermediate,
which then in a second step could close the bond.
Right.
How do we know that the,
whether there is an intermediate like this and the reaction or whether we just
have a transition state that we just drew where both of the bonds are being
formed at once.
What experimental tests could one perform to see whether both bonds are being
formed at once?
Anybody got an idea?
Yeah.
Chris,
do you have any idea of how you can tell whether two bonds are being formed at
once?
Pardon me?
Well,
do you have any idea?
Have you ever seen an example before where you can tell that two bonds are being
formed at once and not
one bond at a time?
I skate out of here.
Okay.
The rates are one way.
One tries to do things like that.
Roy Stereo,
chemistry of the product.
Because if you have this intermediate,
if it lasts longer than about 10 to the minus 10 seconds,
that's how long it takes a single bond to rotate
something like that.
Okay,
so you've been wrote it.
This was a double bond before,
so these two methyls were cyst to one another.
Both going back into the board.
Right.
But if you get this thing with a single bond that it could rotate in about 10 to
the minus 10 seconds to have this methyl coming out in front.
The other metal still in back.
Right?
And now if that one and you,
you should do that if you can,
because this is less strained.
Can anybody see why this one would be less strain than that one,
Laura?
Right in this one,
this methyl is between this CBR too and this ch three it's Gauche to both of
them or something like that.
But here it's rotated to be far from the methyl,
right.
So it's,
it's a,
it's much less strain here,
but it's not between the two groups here.
It's between the CBR too in the hydrogen,
although I've drawn it as if a word clips,
right?
Okay.
So if this is this and it goes and doesn't rotate,
this product will be sis.
The two methyls will be on the same side of the ring,
both going back into the board.
But if this happens,
the product will be trans.
So you do the reaction and you find that since starting material gives only sis
product,
so there wasn't the opportunity for rotation,
right?
Therefore,
it must have formed both bonds either at the same time or within a really,
really short period of time.
So fundamentally what you did here is time,
how fast this could have been,
how fast this,
this closure could have been by knowing something about how rapidly things
rotate,
right?
You know,
it must be this,
this collapse must be faster than rotation.
So it doesn't really prove that there's not an intermediate,
but it proves that it doesn't last longer than if there is one.
It doesn't last longer than 10 to the minus 10 seconds,
which is roughly the rate at which you would rotate,
okay?
Now the second example was hydro [inaudible] oxidation.
So remember we said that if you had a B h Bond,
you can add it across a double bond,
right?
And then treat that in a second oxidation step by reacting with hydrogen
peroxide and hydroxide.
And that replaces br to which people don't want with Oah,
which is a kind of compound that people do want.
Okay.
Now,
so what we've,
what this process,
the two steps,
hydro duration in that oxidation achieves addition of water to the CC double
bond.
All right?
Have you,
do you know any other ways to add water to a CC,
double bond,
hydrogen plus and water?
That's what we,
you know,
Eddie Hoh,
Auto Bot,
uh,
oxy,
mercury,
aeration and reduction,
which we just talked about also forms the alcohol.
Why do you need another way to make an alcohol?
Sebastian?
Ah,
it's antinarcotic off.
Let's look at how this happens.
Okay,
so here's the Bh three,
which is an electrified because of the vacant orbital on Boron,
right?
And this is the motion that'll happen.
It,
these electrons that are in the double bond go into Bond Boron.
But at the same time,
these electrons that Bh bond and unusually high homo,
why is that an unusually hot
[inaudible] charges or charges?
So it's a high energy or,
but all for the same reason that bonds the chlorine or low in energy right now,
there's not much nuclear charge on this one.
So this nucleophile is attacking Pi Star at the same time.
So we could again watch this,
watch the stretch and shrink as it goes toward the transition state.
So,
so we're breaking this bond,
forming the ch bond and for being,
uh,
BC bond.
Okay.
So,
uh,
here we've looked at,
here we're looking at the orbital so that the,
uh,
Lubo on the Bh three is the p orbital,
the whole Hobo of the,
of the outies as this pie,
right?
The Hobo on the Bh three is that,
that,
uh,
Bh bond and the Lubo of the,
of the,
uh,
the Alkane is this thing which looks ugly.
But the reason is that I've just started to be in the shape that would have half
the transition state awkward started.
Okay.
So that was the transition state.
And you can see that,
that,
uh,
that it makes us homos and Lumos Lumos and Hobos.
Okay.
So then this,
then the staff,
this then establishes a BC bond.
Now the particular one we are been,
it has art and our group on the beat here,
I've drawn Bethel.
If this had been formed by additional B h two a double bond,
there would be another carbon here,
right?
There would have been a double bond boron on to one end.
Hydrogen added to the other.
Right?
But I've made it,
uh,
for simplicity,
made it a methyl group just so we wouldn't have as much to deal with.
And now I've got to look at the second step,
the oxidation.
So what's the Lumos is going to be involved in this reaction?
Luke,
what do you say?
Okay,
well,
if it's going to be vacant,
it's not going to be the sigma could be sick of star,
but that's not the Luma.
There's a lower orbit.
All the fat off the top of the rock cod.
It's Derek,
ah,
boron VX three from last semester and the vacant orbital onboard.
So it has an atomic particle.
It hasn't mixed with anything.
So the lowest orbital is the orbital lawn.
Boron.
What's the High Homo?
What's going to react?
Ab you got an idea
that's crazy.
Very well,
right?
The oxygen that has a negative charge on it.
So we can just mix those two.
Okay.
So we've got this and now there's a,
we draw a negative charge on boron because it gained half interest in the pair
of electrons that was on oxygen.
Okay?
And now we have an interesting uh,
rearrangement that looks a lot like sn two.
Okay.
Where is there a low Lumo here
in this molecule?
Linda,
you have idea
came your role?
Yeah,
the Sigma Star of,
Oh,
because of the high Decleor charge,
right?
Like seal two or something like that.
So low little moe here.
Where is there a high homo
wells?
We've got the idea.
When you look up this whole thing here,
what is there that tells you that there could be a high on level?
Aha.
The negative charge.
Okay,
so,
but that negative charge is not an unshared pair of electrodes.
There aren't any unshared electrons on the Boron.
So what is the orbital?
It's,
it has to be one of the sigma bonds to Boron.
For example,
this sigma bond here.
So here we have a nuclear file,
and here we have an electrified.
Here's the Hobo Sigma stars,
the Lumo.
Okay,
now here's the geometry of the transition state.
You see what's happening is that the ch three is moving over,
taking these electrons with it.
It's a meth.
I'd shift like we saw in the cad,
I am cases,
except that that case there would be a cad ion here,
right?
And the ch three with just electrons would shift to give a more stable cad ions.
In this case it's because you have the o bond.
But it's interesting to compare this transition state with the transition state
for an sn two reaction of say,
chloride attacking methyl chloride.
So you can see,
here's the nuclear file,
the leaving group,
here's the nucleophile,
okay.
And in fact,
if we,
the sick,
the star cbrs being attacked here,
alright,
get that reaction,
the sn two.
But in this case is sigma star.
Oh,
oh.
And Sigma BC is the nuclear file.
So you see,
it looks like the same reaction.
And in fact,
if we,
if we go to the transition state,
you see the thing bouncing back and forth to the transition state.
But if we look at the orbitals,
so the transition state,
this is the homo for sn two.
This is the home for this rearrangement.
See the orbitals look almost exactly the same.
And if you look at the lube oil for the sn two and the Lumo for this
rearrangement,
it's the same reaction as I said to this rearrangement is,
okay.
So,
uh,
so this is the question then that that,
that Sebastian is already at,
uh,
answered.
Why do this procedure if all it does is add h and o h to c double bond.
See how about the regio chemistry and how about the stereochemistry?
So that initial addition ads,
Br br is now the low Lumo in that initial edition before the rearrangement in
the initial audition B is the electrified.
So it adds to the less substituted carbon to make because so that you get more
of the carpet cad I in character here and the hydride is what shifts.
Remember,
it's the hydride,
it's B as the electro file.
And the Bh bond with the hydride shifting is the,
is the nucleophile.
So it goes to the more substituted center.
So whereas Markovnikov,
of course,
knew nothing about homos and Lou bows nucleophile and electro files,
all he knew was that the hydrogen went to the place that had the few,
the most hydrogens.
And the other thing went where there were the most non hydrogens,
right?
But the other thing in this case is B,
B r two,
right?
Which turns out to be the electrified file,
not the nucleophile and the other cases.
The other thing,
not hydrogen was the nucleophile.
Now it's the electrified.
So it does,
it gives the opposite orientation here for what mark cognitive cost probably
would have said,
but for the same reason that explains Markovnikov addition,
right?
And now when we do the rearrangement,
well,
uh,
what we do is put the oxygen on Boron and then have this whole art group shift
over.
But that's a front side attack.
It's the,
it's a sigma orbitals of the,
of,
of this,
uh,
of this RBR bond that are doing the attacking,
right.
So,
uh,
so it,
it's front side at that,
that it comes,
it replaces the,
the,
Oh,
replaces the Oah replaces br two.
It does not a backside situation.
Right?
So you get that.
So it's a,
so the alcohol product is sin.
The,
the two things that have added are on the same phase,
not an opposite faces.
Right.
And it's anti Markov off the Oah.
Now is,
is on the opposite place or where I would go by these other mechanisms of adding
in the alcohol.
So this is a great boon then if you're in the synthesis business and need to
prepare an alcohol where the Oah is on,
the more substitute is on the less substituted carbon.
So it's anti Markovnikov.
So you contrast that with acid catalyzed hydration,
which would give this cat it,
right?
Which is,
who are part of this alcohol,
which is the Markov knockoff product.
How about the stereo chemistry in this place was that sister was,
it said edition or anti edition at the age and a Ooh,
come in on the same face or opposite faces.
Cassey
can't hear.
You can't tell here.
Right?
Because there are two H's.
So it's a,
it's a clear choice.
In this case,
when it was anti mark called off,
one is Marcotte Macarthur.
The age goes where there are already ages.
There's going to be this ambiguity.
Unless you did what but a deuter deuterium in,
then you could tell that it is sin.
Okay?
But it appears random.
Oh,
oh no.
Pardon me.
Not only appears random,
if you did it with deuterium,
you would find that it is random because you generate a cat eye and intermediate
here when you add protons first.
Right?
And that could be attacked from either side.
So it sin here,
but random down here.
And that's enough for today.